what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some exciting and also
some not so exciting news about
spider-man no way home depending on how
you view this new information about the
film it is coming as a rather odd
surprise but i'll let you be the judge
of whether or not you think this is good
or bad news we have a trailer update
that is good news and then we have some
news about the sinister six or i should
say the sinister five as there's been a
new report on who the villains could be
in spider-man no way home of course i'll
break down everything you need to know
in this video and if you love marvel and
spider-man be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos and if
you love spider-man we are giving away a
spider-man action figure by variant
bring arts to enter all you have to do
subscribe to my channel and my other
channel cosmic culture so right away i
know everybody wants to know about that
trailer especially after yesterday there
was a lot of conflicting reports
yesterday and at some point there were
rumors going around that the second
trailer wasn't even done and that it had
some type of problem and that it
probably wasn't going to be done anytime
soon or before the eternals however it
seems like this was quickly proven wrong
and in fact the opposite was true the
spider-man noah home second official
trailer is actually done we've learned
this because the korean government
website where ads and trailers get
raided approve the second spider-man no
way home trailer we even have a
screenshot of this so it is indeed done
because how can you approve something
that's not done so since it's completed
and approved in korea we can assume that
it's completed everywhere and although
we don't have a specific trailer date
right now insiders say that it's
probably coming within the next two
weeks and i've also heard that we should
be getting it before november 15th but
unfortunately that is all that i've
heard but i sure do hope we get it
before november 15th because at that
point that's only a month away from the
movie's release that is just extremely
close to the movie to be releasing the
first official full trailer but i think
as everybody knows the marketing for
spider-man no way home that sony and
marvel have been doing are way different
than anything that we've seen in the
past but hey the hype is huge probably
bigger than endgame so whatever they're
doing it's working but they obviously
know that fans are getting a little
upset that we haven't seen that full
trailer yet now the second piece of news
that we have today is about the sinister
six or i should say the villains of the
film and this report is coming from my
buddies over on twitter big screen leaks
i've talked to them many times i know
that they are reliable and yesterday
they said by the way rhino isn't in
spiderman no way home he is frequently
talked about and is the butt of many
jokes but he's not in the film rhino i
think is a rumor that got thrown out as
leaks and there were many many fake
photos of rhino and all of this
eventually led to everybody just kind of
saying that he was in the movie and it
did make sense and i even thought he was
going to be in the movie as well but
according to bsl he is not going to be
in the movie however he is going to be
talked about which may have been where
all the confusion might have come from
but if you're wondering who the sixth
villain actually is going to be
according to big screen leaks
no one that's right according to them
there is no sixth villain it's just
going to be a sinister five now this is
a rather odd decision you have five
villains why not go for one more to make
it the sinister six and have that movie
but perhaps this really isn't a sinister
six movie perhaps it's just a
multiversal movie and we just happen to
have other villains coming from other
universes and other spiderman it does
kind of seem like a missed opportunity
but you never really know what sony has
up their sleeve you never really know
what their plans are for their own sony
universe and the mcu moving forward we
know that tom holland is probably going
to be coming back a spider-man and you
have to wonder well what's next if you
have the spider-verse the other two
spider-man and all of these other
villains coming back how do you top that
well we know venom is eventually going
to be coming and facing off against
spider-man and perhaps we will get a
true spider-man and the sinister six
film and i think some people really like
this but i think a lot of people don't
like it as well because we were just one
villain away from having the entire
sinister six but i know some people
would like to see our spider-man tom
holland just him alone going up against
the sinister six him doing it by himself
some people kind of complained that we
never really get our spider-man on his
own kind of having to fend for himself
he was taken under the wing of tony
stark now he's being taken under the
wing kind of of doctor strange and then
the other two spider-man when is he
going to be on his own and it is
possible that that's what sony might
have up their sleeve are spider-man vs a
sinister six perhaps one that they've
already established in the mcu vulture
scorpion chameleon perhaps mysterio is
still alive so there are villains that
could still be the sinister six that are
spider-man could go up against
unfortunately we don't have that much
longer to wait until we see the actual
film only about a month and a half now
and it's still very weird that we don't
have that trailer yet but hopefully that
is coming soon as well in the meantime
let me know what you think about this
very very interesting news of there only
being 5 villains in spider-man no way
home leave your thoughts down below in
the comments don't forget to like this
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram twitter and tick
tock and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you